your book Patty Hearst to this day
claims I was brainwashed not you what's
that you said I I was bringing oh yeah
yeah when I was a networks yeah that's
uh trust me that was it happened in 93
and we're still trying to dig that ship
out no but what you say in the book is
you do not buy that she was brainwashed
you're just not finds IIIi I don't I
mean what do you think happens she's
kidnapped which was real she was totally
at home must have been terrifying but
what happened she was nineteen years old
when she was kidnapped she was very
young she was in a very restless and
difficult moment in her life she was
engaged to be married to this fellow
Stephen weed but very unhappy with him
she didn't get along with her mother who
didn't approve of her relationship with
Steven weed so she was sort of at sea
she was developing a bit of a political
consciousness and she was surrounded by
these people the the the the these
radical terrorists the Symbionese
Liberation Army and they started talking
to her like an equal like a partner and
she saw that they had an answer a lot of
people thought radical crazy politics
had an answer in those days and if you
look at her behavior over this year and
a half you know all the crimes she
committed all the opportunities she had
to escape I think she did become a
member of the SLA even though she never
would have done it obviously had she not
been kidnapped
I'm curious there's a there's a line
that you can draw between what happened
to Patty Hearst and what we're seeing in
the world right now which is you have
these young people that are being
radicalized by Isis and there's a lot of
people like most people watching right
now who think I don't understand why
someone who comes from a middle-class
family would leave that family go to
another land go into these teachings and
then put a bomb on their chest and
detonate it and this was the story that
we were hearing in 1974-75 it's the same
thing at play again it's it's very
similar and that and that's why the
story has felt so topicals to me because
we look at you know kids whether it's in
Minneapolis where there have been people
radicalized or Brussels or Paris
and most of them wind up saying of
course I know we don't want anything to
do with terrorism but a handful do and
we don't there is no magic formula for
why some people become radicalized and
some don't and of course it's always a
bad decision
it's self-destructive its destructive of
the broader society but it happens and
it happened here
Patty Hearst not a fan of this book I'm
guessing I have not heard back but we
did have one conversation during the
when I was reporting because I I called
her up I had sent emails and I said
Patricia this this is Jeff Toobin and
she said Oh God click and so I you know
I was getting these mixed signals from
her and no but she didn't want a
participant I'm gonna help ya would you
yeah I got you I'm gonna fix things up
with OJ yeah trust going to work I
needed to come to me first
you